US government planes today have
evacuated hundreds more Americans from
China's coronavirus outbreak but we're
following a growing cruise ship a
growing crisis rather aboard cruise
ships one of them docked in Japan now
has 61 confirmed cases of coronavirus
including nine Americans and another
ship is under quarantine in Hong Kong
the two vessels together carry about
7,300 people and this morning and you're
looking at a picture here from Bayonne
New Jersey that is just outside New York
City where the anthem of the Seas just
came into port with at least a dozen
passengers who will be tested for signs
of coronavirus overall there are now
more than 30 1500 confirmed cases
worldwide at least 638 patients have
died and that includes a Chinese doctor
who tried to warn the world about a
month ago
Ramey Inocencio is in Hong Kong ramie
good morning what's the latest reaction
sure and good morning China right now is
being massively rocked by anger as well
as grief by the death of dr. Leland
young the government had first accused
him of spreading rumors he has now been
vindicated
tragically with his death but as you
just mentioned with more than 31,000
people infected around the world and
more than 600 deaths not to mention
about 8,000 people here in Hong Kong as
well as in Japan across two cruise ships
now quarantined for fear that people had
been infected with coronavirus onboard
the diamond princess
health officials cautiously removed
another 41 people their tests for
coronavirus positive the past two days
this massive luxury ship has been
quarantined in Yokohama Japan 3,700
people may have been exposed to the
highly infectious disease Jerry
Jorgensen from Utah watched from her
balcony as the sick were taken away then
we found out that we were going to be on
14 day quarantine on board other
stressed American passengers described
rising tensions between health
authorities and people who say they
aren't being told if and when they might
go home I was devastated when we got
there was I would spy star you know I
was crying pretty hysterically because
we have kids have jobs in the city of
Wuhan the epicenter of this crisis
nearly 60 million people are still on
government lockdown the healthy have
been told to stay indoors and to report
violators their neighbors anyone to the
police
while the suspected six still crammed
into hospitals running short on supplies
this video from social media which CBS
News can't independently verify claims
to show this warehouse now converted
into a quarantine center the infected
lying helpless and in close proximity
with claims of no bathrooms no running
water and no doctors when asked who was
in charge this woman replied no one more
social media from inside shows
disappointment even anger and on the
outskirts of Wuhan frantic efforts to
contain the virus have now yielded to
hospitals built in just the past few
weeks to isolate and treat the infected
praised by government officials on state
media and the screws keep tightening on
any travelers coming from mainland China
the government here in Hong Kong has
said that starting Saturday just a few
hours from now anyone any travelers
coming across that border right there
will be strictly confined to a 14-day
quarantine and anyone exhibiting
symptoms could also have to wear GPS
armbands so the government can monitor
their every move make a very serious
situation rainy Inocencio force in hong
kong thank you